oh hi everybody i'm chris kohler and you
are watching game life hey guess what we
fit is finally out in North America it
is available today and Nintendo is going
to send in a personal trainer and he is
going to get me totally ripped and it's
going to be probably a really really
hard job and after that got Alex handy
here he's a wired magazine contributor
and fellow video game collector and
we're going to talk about buying old
retro games at flea markets and thrift
stores all around the city and show you
some of our best vines okay Paul what
are we gonna do first we're gonna do the
half moon pose alright the yoga move
great for balance stability corn trunk
flexibility and stability as well so are
you ready I am ready i've been i've been
doing this but maybe I haven't been
doing it the right way so let me know
okay Oh guys take a look at it and we'll
go from there alright let's start off
great so you're in good position okay
don't forget to breathe and what I love
so much about this is that you actually
get to track your progress breathing and
you're getting this really great
feedback about your center of gravity
and how you're working hula hooping
you're familiar with this one right I'm
familiar with the concept yes okay well
you're gonna hoo loop using your trunk
mmm getting that nice good circular
motion going keeping that hoop up at the
whole time so it's it's pretty much just
like this and you exactly the whole body
going exactly and it's easy for the
first five seconds and also may I point
out to everyone watching this is the
sexiest thing you will see today this is
an option to catch other hoops which
will actually incorporate more muscles
of your body so if you're laying into
that there you go yeah that one go on
now you're increasing the movement in
your body still keeping the core moving
getting that cardiovascular work as well
so you're you're working out the other
thing is that as a gamer you're
constantly challenged to like beat your
score on these things so I mean the more
hula hoops you get
the more of the higher your score really
good at this I've been doing this so
Paul I'm really sweating up a storm here
actually after my prob eloping but I
really wanted to ask you before you go
as a fitness expert what what do you
think about we fit from the fitness
perspective I think that we fit is
amazing because it's going to give you
all that feedback that you lack in your
life if you don't have something giving
that V back to you so what's great about
is you are working in musculature it
hits every facet of fitness so it's
cardiovascular it's got the flexibility
and the fund balance games so it's not
only is it fun but it's just a great way
to get started or even if you're like a
weekend warrior it keeps you going it
keeps you on track it's a fantastic tool
for that as well well yeah well i mean
i've been using it for quite a while i
really enjoy it and you can buy it now
to its out May nineteenth so um you know
you can go on the ebay now and find any
kind of old retro video game that you
can possibly imagine you're gonna pay a
pretty high price for it you can have it
any any childhood treasure that you used
to have you can find it whether it's dr.
Mario or phantasy star 2 or even the
little statues of Mario these to sell
back in the 80s but for me see I don't
really do that I like collecting retro
video games but it's about the thrill of
the hunt absolutely there's nothing
quite like digging through a box of
random cartridges CDs etc and coming
across that one turbo graphics game or
one impossible to find PlayStation 1 RPG
but you can still kind of rip yourself
off if you're going to flea markets tag
sales thrift stores if you're if you're
buying stuff that you can actually even
maybe even get cheaper on ebay so here's
here's some of the stuff that we found
alexsa what'swhat's we know one of the
more interesting things here for you
well we've got some of course the holy
grail for most toad endo files is the
game watch and unfortunately when i
found this one at the laney college flea
market in oakland the fellow who had it
knew what it was and charged me thirty
dollars oh okay which is pretty much the
going rate for this without the box
mm-hmm but still if you ever see game
and watches certainly snap them up yeah
nintendo used to make these their old
LCD video games when you probably played
a lot of these when you were a kid maybe
not the nintendo brand but yeah there's
Super Mario once there's Legend of Zelda
ones and they made quite a few of them
but they are actually kind of rare they
affect your pretty high price in Tokyo
so yeah I mean a you know actually
paying 30 bucks for one of these isn't
that bad
too bad paying 30 bucks for an old Super
Nintendo cartridge even if it's a you
know Chrono Trigger might be getting a
little ripped off would you pay for this
one actually I got this at a computer
recycling center in Berkeley it was
brought in by a young woman who was
recycling her Super Nintendo my wife was
excited to see that she was also an RPG
fan and there were some final fantasies
but of course Chrono Trigger was the
real gem there and i would i would take
issue with your $30 evaluation to this
oh really because a sealed copy of this
one for 1400 on ebay well a sealed copy
yeah it's a lot different than a
certainly certainly right and then the
boxed copies will always be worth more
like your 5200 games yeah that's the
thing this is something that I found
actually in a thrift store in San
Francisco it's called zenji it's a game
for the Atari 5200 by Activision and
it's actually one of the more rare Atari
5200 games but the thing is it's
actually still sealed still in the box
you know you get the seam in the back
there meeting you know this is this is
as mint as MIT comes now the thing with
sealed games is that there really is no
because there are so few of them it's
hard to figure out what the price is
there are no like price guides that tell
you exactly how much sealed games are
going to be actually there well not the
sealed ones but there are price guides
for the Box cup oh there there there
there are price guides out there digital
press com is a good place to go and get
video game prizes video game collector
magazine is my personal favorite right
quarterly and it's just like a comic
book guide and unfortunately for you
know collectors like me the only way
that I could actually figure out how
much somebody would pay for this would
be to actually put it on ebay and see
what would happen when two people
started fighting over it same thing with
this now this I I couldn't really find a
lot of information on when I first
bought it it's it's a game called
journey escape you had the band Journey
made a video game for for the Atari 2600
but this is actually the version that
they would send out to stores to put in
their Atari demo machines so that people
could come over and check the game out
and it's got a serial number on it there
were only a couple hundred of these made
and again just just sort of turned up in
a thrift store you know so if you're
going to your local thrift stores you
know always look always ask if they have
any video games anywhere you know you
never know what you might turn up
absolutely and and on that subject see
I've made some pretty good finds i would
consider I would consider these two to
be to be pretty good thrift store finds
for retro video games but I'll
clicks and the reason why i asked him
here today as it turns out basically
wins at life for this this amazing flea
market find that he just made us out it
was at the laney college flea market out
in the east bay and okay Alex what a
month ago now about a month ago now uh
well it's hard to see in these static
bags but there are little chips in here
you'll notice so i found a lot of about
fifty eeproms these little chips that
were made in the early 80s and were used
for contra console video games this is
what you would develop a game on you
would burn it to one of these chips seat
it into this sort of a board and then
slide it into your console and that's
how you would write for it I'm like now
or you have a development version of an
xbox or you have to write a specific
console yeah all of these chips if
inserted these boards will run on as it
turns out the colecovision yes these are
for uh but the the fine that I made
which included two unknown colecovision
games swords the sword and the sorcerer
and Dragon Slayer for colecovision also
included some chips for the Atari 2600
which I have bare right under here this
is a really interesting thing about
these these games I mean is there there
there unreleased I mean occasionally
people will find unreleased retro video
games you know in the form of eeproms
development chips at flea markets but
you pretty much found what three games
that had never before been seen had been
believed to maybe exist but we actually
have the games on these absolutely and
it's it's kind of silly frankly the end
the game I found but it's actually not
that bad of a game it's for the Atari
2600 and it's called Cabbage Patch Kids
adventures in the park now there's a bit
of a story behind it originally it was a
Japanese game for the MSX which was
Sony's home computer system okay and
then it was ported to the colecovision
right actually released as Cabbage Patch
Kids adventures in the park but the
colecovision in the Atari 2600 were
completely different systems so it was
needed it when they wanted to release it
for the Atari they had to rewrite it
completely now I don't know if your
viewers know this but Kaliko the company
that did colecovision also owned Cabbage
Patch try to make an average price so
the 80s was very lucrative for them yeah
not only did we get Cabbage Patch Kids
adventures the park which had not been
played by anyone who'd spoken about it
since 1984 mhm
we also got 12 revisions of it so the
actual process of development as we
checked the roms and saw what was added
when and how it evolved and that's
that's really amazing yeah well thank
you very much for being here today this
is really exciting hey thanks for having
me and now I pretty much know that none
of my flea market finds that I ever make
or going to be as good as this but
you